it is quiet this morning in kenosha
wisconsin one of the cities where the
president called for law and order
protests over the police shooting of
jacob blake continued for a fifth day
blake is still recovering from multiple
gunshot wounds kyle rittenhouse the
teenager charged with killing two people
during tuesday night's protest is before
appearing before a judge this morning
mololenki has the latest developments
from kenosha
we do not wish to be known for violence
of any kind kenosha wisconsin has become
an unwilling home to two tragedies one
stemming from the other first last
sunday officials say 29 year old jacob
blake was shot in the back seven times
by kenosha police officer rustin chesky
blake who's now paralyzed from the waist
down is recovering in the hospital we've
learned a new detail blake is being
handcuffed to his hospital bed at a
press conference wisconsin governor tony
evers was asked if he was concerned
blake is being handcuffed hell yes i i
couldn't i
know
i would have no personal understanding
why that would be necessary certainly
he's paid a
horrific price already the wisconsin
department of justice is investigating
the shooting officer chesky has not been
charged wisconsin lieutenant governor
mandela barnes we don't need an
investigation to know that blake's
shooting falls in a long and painful
pattern of violence and this is a
pattern of violence that happens
against black lives too often across
this country it's a history that brandon
morris a mentor and native of kenosha
says african americans live with every
day
make sure
you don't make any sudden moves
when you're around police officers
make sure you're quiet
when you're walking through a white
neighborhood so all those things
are mental models that are built up
where in the black community our parents
are teaching us these things because
they want to protect us and they want us
to be prepared the second tragedy came
tuesday when
year 17-year-old kyle rittenhouse
allegedly shot three people who had
gathered to protest blake's shooting 36
year old joseph rosenbaum and 26 year
old anthony huber were killed hannah
giddings was huber's girlfriend and it's
just not fair that he had to die like
that like
he just turned 26 like we were
we had plans for everything like
we had plans for everything
well after extradition kyle rittenhouse
is ultimately expected to face a judge
here at the kenosha county courthouse
his attorney tells cbs news that he had
the right to defend himself here on the
streets of kenosha meanwhile just this
morning the wisconsin the department of
justice released the names of the other
two officers involved in the jacob blake
shooting officers brittany maronick and
vincent arenas all the officers involved
in that shooting are currently on leave
throughout the course of the
investigation gail mull you said
something interesting in your piece
about jacob blake being handcuffed to a
bed have you heard any explanation about
why a man that doctors say is paralyzed
has to be handcuffed to the bed
still unclear why we know that he's
paralyzed we know that he's going to be
in the hospital for some time still
undergoing surgery so it's unclear to us
why at this point he remains uh
handcuffed we have reached out to police
but at this point police are not taking
any questions from the media gail all
right mola lange thank you very much